翻訳: Ryo Okube
校正: Hiroko Kawano
皆さんこんにちは
HAIOKAです
僕はエレクトロニックミュージック
というものを作っています
エレクトロニックミュージック
というのは
例えば シンセサイザーとコンピュータ
を使ったそれでつくる音楽ですね
そして僕は
そのエレクトロニックミュージックに
自分のお婆ちゃんから譲り受けた筝
一般的には琴と呼ばれる楽器なんですけど
それと自分の声
それから生活音
例えば キッチンでの
ガチャガチャっていう音だったり
外を通る車の[音]だったり
そういうものをマイクで録音して
エレクトロニックミュージックと
混ぜ合わせています
自分がこの作業をなぜやるか?
それが すごく
自分にとって 大事なことで
僕は 今この日本を生きている自分の
生活や感覚を
音楽で表現したいと思っています
今の日本っていうのは
伝統と最先端が混ざり合った
そんな世界だと思うんです
例えば、簡単な話
モダンなカフェやビルが並ぶ街並みの
一角にあるお稲荷さんだったり
もっと身近な話で言えば
スマートフォンで年賀状を送る
とかもそうだと思うんです
僕はそういうのを
全然否定する気は無くて
だとしたら
その今日本に生きてる
その感覚とかその生活を
音楽で表現できたらなと思っています
一曲演奏しますので
何か皆様に伝わるものがあれば幸いです
よろしくお願いします
(拍手)
(音楽始まり)
(英語歌)
「一頭の若いムースが丘の上に
彼は森の王になったばかり
その目は情熱に溢れ
恐れるものは何も無い
一頭の若いムースが丘の上に
彼は森の王になったばかり
その目は情熱に溢れ
恐れるものは何も無い
冷たい風が吹いている
けれども僕はもう、この家を出よう
これ以上、何もしない傍観者でいるのは
耐えられないから」
（間奏）
（英語歌）
「一頭の若いムースが丘の上に
彼は森の王になったばかり
その目は情熱に溢れ
恐れるものは何も無い
一頭の若いムースが丘の上に
彼は森の王になったばかり
その目は情熱に溢れ
恐れるものは何も無い
冷たい風が吹いている
けれども僕はもう、この家を出よう
これ以上、何もしない傍観者でいるのは
耐えられないから」
（間奏）
（英語歌）
「一頭の若いムースが丘の上に
彼は森の王になったばかり
その目は情熱に溢れ
恐れるものは何も無い
冷たい風が吹いている
けれども僕はもう、この家を出よう
これ以上、何もしない傍観者でいるのは
耐えられないから
冷たい風が吹いている
けれども僕はもう、この家を出よう
これ以上、何もしない傍観者でいるのは
耐えられないから」
（間奏）
（英語歌）
「冷たい風が吹いている
けれども僕はもう、この家を出よう
これ以上、何もしない傍観者でいるのは
耐えられないから」
(音楽終)
ありがとうございました
(拍手)